laura good afternoon how are we doing my
dad is an
alcoholic and a very skilled liar
he's stolen money from my family i mean
too many times to count
including my little sisters
yet in my eyes at least i always feel
like he's the victim right i always feel
sorry for him
um and another thing i think is
important for you to know just for this
call
um is that my stepdad who helped raise
me
sadly took his life when i was 18. oh
man
yeah so i'm 29 now um
and my question is how do i avoid the
hurt
that follows every new lie and betrayal
from my dad
um but i'm still hoping for some kind of
normal
father-daughter relationship in my life
or should i just
stop hoping and pursuing this
relationship with him all together
yeah laura you've got to let the fantasy
go
okay and there's a nagging
question that lives deep inside your
heart way
there deep in there past where the mris
can see
that just asks almost on a daily basis
what was so wrong with laura that her
dad wouldn't love her
what was so wrong with laura that even
her stepdad wouldn't stay around
yeah and what i need you to hear me say
is
that wasn't your fault
your biological dad was sick
he's hurting in a way that he couldn't
manage and so he had to come up with
other alternative behaviors to
to manage that hurt and
it's natural and normal for you to ask
why not me
what was what was it about me that
wasn't good enough to love and i need
you to not ever ask that question again
because it wasn't about you
okay okay and when you think why did my
stepdad reach out to me
if he would just have called what could
i have done i need you to never ask
yourself that question
because he wasn't well okay
yeah he was so right and he didn't reach
out he didn't call
no and he was just gone didn't leave
anything
right no letter no nothing so and so
laura
since you were about five
or six or seven you've had a little girl
who has been working overtime to get men
to love her
to try to figure out a new strategy a
new way to get her dad to love
and care about her
and it's built up a universe very
similar to
whatever the arendelle whatever the
frozen
you know the frozen movies right it's
just become its own planet right
and every time there's a holiday rolling
up or every time he just shows up
unexpectedly and says hey i'm coming by
man that castle door is fling open you
put on your dress and your makeup and
this is going to be the time and then he
leaves a mess and he leaves you with the
check or
you find out from your little brother
that he borrowed something and didn't
give it back which is another word for
stealing
and filling the blank fill in the blank
and you get hurt over and over again
so here's what you have to do for your
soul for
any relationship you're gonna have
moving forward is you have to let that
fantasy go
you have to grieve the loss you should
have had a dad who loved you more than
life itself and i hate to be the guy
but you didn't you don't
and that doesn't mean you're not worthy
of being loved okay
okay so you have to let that go and then
you've got to do the hard hard work
of and this is this is the demon of
growing up in an alcoholic home
the only way you get whole laura the
only way you get whole
is through relationships and the thing
that has hurt you over and over and over
in your life
is relationships and so you have to
lean in to other people and risk getting
hurt
again because that's the only path
towards
healing and that sucks doesn't it
it's hard yeah yeah i mean
you're so um you're so insightful you
know we've just been talking for like
60 seconds and you've you've really just
narrowed everything down
um i'm fortunate to be
in a wonderful marriage my husband is
amazing awesome and a god-loving man
and so you know we um i'm just so
grateful and appreciative for that um
but the other side of it is i have two
little sisters you know
25 year old and a 16 year old and um
so much of you know what i had to find
out about my dad i found out as i was
growing up and part of me
just fears for the 16 year old and
you know i know i didn't verbalize that
question but i guess it's just
a kind of a continuation like how do i
protect her from
him stealing more money from her and uh
you know but without ruining her you
know the idea of her dad that she's got
in her head as a 16 year old
and so what i would tell you laura is
you're not ruining that idea
you're protecting her he's ruining that
idea because he sucks as a dad
right and any dad who steals money from
his daughter for
alcohol any father who steals from his
children
any father who does not spend every
moment they have making sure those his
daughters know how beautiful they are
how lovely they are how strong and
smart and ninja like they are any dad
who doesn't put that investment in
isn't worth that title of dad and so
you're not
poisoning the image what you're doing is
you're putting words to the pain that
your sister feels
she knows that her dad isn't whole right
she knows that you know what she's doing
she definitely knows
she's doing what you did which is blame
herself for it and try to solve that
right right yeah because he has just
this ability to seem like
you know poor me of course it's like
poor me why is all this happening to me
you know
yes still this hot shot dad that's right
and here's what the daughter and son of
an addict does they spend their whole
life trying to make sure dad's okay
and it's exhausting because
true addicts prey on that because it
keeps them from ever having to face the
world on their own because somebody's
always there trying to make it okay
and the earlier you can turn that light
switch on for your sister
not that she's not gonna not love that
guy that's her dad that's your dad
right right you love him but i'm not
gonna give him my heart anymore
i'm not going to give him my a fantasy
anymore
i'm going to draw my boundaries to
protect me and my family
if he shows up for thanksgiving it's
going to be on my terms
and he will not be drinking we will not
give him money he will not stay at the
house and when he says well
just don't have a place well that stinks
dad we love you man
we'll see you soon because these are the
boundaries that are going to keep our
families safe
and that's not a dishonorable way of
interacting with your father it's a way
of
protecting yourself against an abusive
person
right and absolutely you have a
husband that loves you you have won the
lottery you've put the work in
relationally
and i want you to do the deep work
potentially with your husband maybe make
it 20 21 this is the this is the year
y'all gonna go on a marriage retreat
maybe the first time ever and i want you
to really mind your soul
and find out how much of your
relationship with your incredible
awesome husband is built on
not not a co-created relationship
together
not a co-creative future together but
you making sure he's okay too
if you've managed to avoid that you're
better than most my guess is
that you are living a life of full
support and honor and love
but sometimes that comes at the expense
of your soul and what i don't want you
to do is wake up when you're 40 and go
whoa what happened
wow right right and so
this is a beautiful moment for you to
say husband
let's just call him tom hey tom i
won the lottery with you and you're a
great good man
and i'm going to start letting the
fantasy of my dad go
and it may mean that my little sister is
going to spend some time with us
right i'm going to teach her how to
budget i'm going to teach her
how to take care of her money i'm gonna
teach her how to apply a college because
dad's not gonna do those things
and what i wanna do over the next few
years i wanna begin to dream together
and that may mean you're gonna take some
college classes that may mean you're
going to have
a child that may mean a whole host of
things that you've never even allowed
yourself to imagine because your world
has been making sure everyone around you
is okay all the time
and eventually that implodes on children
of addicts
and you are worth being loved and your
husband's worth being loved and you all
have something magical and beautiful
right now and so if you're intentional
about it
way way way up front and you're open and
you communicate honestly with one
another
you may need a marriage counselor to
walk not because you're broken but
because
right because your things are so good
and you want them to be better and so
having a coach that's going to walk
alongside you will be awesome
but now this is about rebuilding a new
thing
not constantly picking up somebody
else's lego pieces and trying to stick
them back together
does that make sense absolutely and um
this call was really hard for me to make
but i am i am so grateful
that i did and thank you so much no
thank you for calling and i wanna
you just said something important and
before i let you go i wanna i wanna
honor this
it is hard to have to look in the mirror
and say
i've gotta let my mom go i've gotta let
my dad go
i can't continue in good faith in a good
conscience to do this to myself to my
marriage to my children to whoever to my
brother and sister
because i've got a parent who sucks i
got a parent who continues to hurt i got
a parent who's dealing with their own
demons
and they're expecting their children to
make them okay
and that's not a child's job so laura
that was
i i can't imagine how hard that call was
you're brave
and you're strong you're in the ninja
club way to go dude
and more importantly you just set an
example for millions of people whose
dads
didn't measure up for whose moms had
their own demons in their own fights
and are finally gonna be children who
say i'm not fighting my parents fights
anymore
i'm not i'm gonna take care of my heart
my home
my spiritual walk my family
i'm gonna love and honor them but i'm
not gonna let them have access to my
heart anymore because they hurt me
every single time laura you're a rock
star good for you
next time you're out on the town in
austin have some queso for me i miss the
good mexican food here in nashville and
it's killing me
so have some good queso i would say on
me but i don't even have vinmos i don't
know how i would pay you but you pay for
it and you eat it and say this is for
delony so i appreciate that